she comes to you and then while he's
nearby
you can do things like pen piece teddy
to get notice if someone's a patreon
supporter yes again email oh oh what the
[ __ ] is that noise come in dog I'm
scared oh yeah I remember okay yeah
whenever you hear these noises because
there's something around that you need
to snap with it's here somewhere
this thing so we keep finding these
around how did I do this before I held
in looked a bit
we've already read this fear of
forgetting quitters
Theodore McKenna and my father was a
lumberjack when I was a child he had
offered to take me to the sawmill in the
Black Hills forest he told me stories of
the monsters and witches who live there
I returned to that place after almost 40
years it looked at certainly how I
remembered except for its haunting
emptiness no one was telling the stories
of fierce and curtis anymore there was
not a single soul to pass the legend so
on the logging company disbanded and the
whole the old sawmill was left to rot
but i could not simply let it be
forgotten not before it revealed its
secrets to me not before I learned what
drove my father to take his own life
Oh interesting cute dog this is one of
the tapes this is one of the tapes where
when you watch it you can stop it at
parts let's find a bunny
right yes so this is where we would go
back before the rock was overturned and
then pulls it here and now how do I know
that's my doggy get my flashlight out
like I see things better
hey bullet and we got to find this rock
because it will be back up now
it was overturned because that's how the
guy left it
just make any sense oh okay so it was by
plants like these so I guess we follow
the flowers you might find it ah here we
go my logic was correct
all right but do you think
- happy East Creek timber
maybe we'll finally get some answers
Lord [ __ ] ting engine orders ballot
sniff it go go
what's this there's a condom
I got an achievement for dogs of war
let's move on I don't quite understand
why that's impossible work whatever wait
don't come yeah no was it a just a take
it back I didn't mean to do that I
didn't mean to do that doesn't mean I'm
sorry I'm so annoyed at myself now it's
gonna pet them again how is the audio
guys can you let me know I'm sure it's
okay cuz no studying things that feel
like I should blow that candle it's a
fire hazard yes
who is this Oh God the game crashed okay
ah who's good don't come here come here
you're a good boy I want my dog so bad I
want a big dog like this one it's when I
don't I can cuddle another one
hmmm why that so many don't tags around
when sometimes we get weird texts from
Google that we don't know this is oh
yeah
I just realized okay so wait don't put
up there's a reason why he has this dog
we keep getting flashbacks and we learn
more about the protagonist sort of
playing us he got this dog I'm pretty
sure because he's got PTSD from the war
and the dog helped him through that and
every now and then you'll probably hear
from her again he talks to like his
ex-girlfriend or wife who left him
ultimately because well things were just
really hard I guess with the PTSD we
don't quite know why they split up but
she's still worrying about him and
obviously he's lost in the woods right
now so he's trying not to worry her so
he's always like yeah I'm fine and I'm
like yeah you're really not though but
it's it's cool
game is little oh okay well I can adjust
that turn it up there you go game should
be higher now for you guys
what's going on boy oh no here we go
guys here we go here we go here we go
guys is this
oh no it's another one of these things I
always think this is when the monster
comes but it's just another one of these
weird things so I got someone snarling
on it why can't I bloody find it it's
gotta be around it so much I don't
oh right here
whoa how does that happen
oh my god okay this is one of his moment
so the father like longer you're away
from your dog good more insane you get
seen it have to make sure that you
deliver for his mother the boys love it
love it
sorry
who's a good boy now now it's not the
time okay cool
Oh
I feel like oddly safe though with the
dog as long as I keep looking at him I'm
fine
all right
are you gonna show me what today here or
okay cool
we just keep going dude okay I'm going
for it
[Music]
come on we got this boy just going for
it
Oh God where does he go well that God
stay with me
no no I mean stay with me Oh Street
maybe going over here did
this is a bad idea
nah
oh it's right there
[Music]
I can see it like sitting around
I like that name bullet disease like the
one'd Wesson again that you job
Wow
Oh moving slowly we're taking this time
were you -
why did he go
when when my dog my dog
he's like right back
[Music]
what
dude are they
[Music]
I'm going
get your serve that fiery fine
[Music]
Flores actually Robert
oh damn
we're not doing goodbye now
we're we're in the midst of severe PTSD
this is cool
I wasn't expecting this when I was
playing a Blair Witch game then we can
touch on real life with mental health
issues and experiences
[Applause]
[Applause]
Oh like still playing I thought it was
cutscene
[Applause]
Clayton batches so far though
can't move
[Music]
yeah you too Ramon maybe some of his
mate starting come up because he firs
maybe there are definitely hints towards
that that he feels it's his fault for
the death of some of the comrades okay
ain't no love like it though he's loved
okay yeah okay wait I know what I'm
gonna give you oh wait no not this I'm
gonna give you a
don't smoke report
cuz you is so good there you go buddy
tell me all my bad times what know if
it's like shocking how many times you
give them a snack or pen instead of the
beginning of the game that depending on
how you treat bullet it might change the
way that he acts I'm not sure how state
laws bullet I mean here I don't have any
haptic feedback spencer's well am I the
new PS 5 controller my ambition up yes
why are you taking me
oh thank you it's a good doggie you're a
good dog no no miss creepy things yeah
maybe all that says thanks I guess
can you find anything look around boy
nothing a well in that case stick
closely with me we're going back to the
past
[ __ ] we need to find another way yep
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] okay uh sure
yeah
ah Michael said imagine if you can play
this game mr. dog how yes DLC idea
that's so cool or you could play like
with a friend and your friend is the dog
that would be awesome
Oh No
yeah
oh all right can you show me the way I
don't know buddy good oh thank you
[Music]
although if you are playing with a
friend yeah no offense to my friends but
they probably wouldn't be as useful as
bullet like if I'm lost and he just
shows me the way I think we would both
be lost
excuse me
why you sleep
okay maybe he's not as useful as
dungeons may about to be take it back
take it back I take it back
[Music]
wait is that a railroad track yeah see
where it leads so Mel and I come where
should we go bullet
to the sawmill it's an account I mean
I'm thinking camp sounds favorite isn't
it what do you think dude where are you
do you think camp too
[Applause]
[Music]
think so alright guys I think we're
going to the camp
Darkwing schmuck says painted their
concept right now make sure you state a
patent patent patent pique it
oh it just told me that I have signal so
why don't we get our phone out what what
do you want sir are you yes wait boy Oh
stay here stay here boy okay we're
staying here and we are looking you're
getting our phone out
oh yeah we're playing phone games before
as well that was quite fun hey Montez
have an event I have to be in there an
hour no worries thank you jumping in
anyway hope you have fun at your event
okay so let's chime phone Jess so this
is the girl that I was telling you guys
about the beginning I like ex-partner
hey Jess
just deal wisely just tell her like help
me I'm stuck in the woods
oh hey let's see you run around at dark
money for us for a while
that doesn't really help with your
romancey skills
so you need how long
sorry I can't explain it now I wouldn't
even know where to start just
hey stop it Ellison whatever it is you
want to tell me you can do it once you
get back okay
get out of there he doesn't know how
he's lost
oh and now we have a tax penis
[Applause]
today with me please oh my god that's
creepy
my light just turned off oh no it's not
working
no aah
dude what my lights not turning on no
this is too great I don't like it give
me back a light sauce please
bones it actually isn't working
just turn it down maybe it's overheating
okay cool
we have light um I wasn't gonna do a I
check my message
oh no please I say it's with my creepy
person we have a voice now okay no idea
who that was from that's a weird man Wow
let's go let's go to the camp
there it is
I think no this is the bridge oh wait
what thank you for the follow Kwan and
the absolute jump-scare Jesus Christ
[Music]
[Music]
cause the game has suddenly gotten super
loud for you guys Wow
yep stay here
it's a minecart
just need a crane real cars
come here are you I'll give you it let
me give you a cuddle yeah good talk
jump off
but going on a ride let's do this power
switch Florida backward reliever
so this is the power [ __ ] oh the way I
need it on and I need to go wait
I guess not backwards
for what
oh we go
what
dude his team
[Music]
okay that's obviously something else we
have to do
[Music]
wells was this thenn
it's a brake lever somewhere brake lever
that little little one
where's a little break leave alone
let's put this in the middle so that you
don't just go off with ours where's oh
there there you are
why that's the break
now we going
[Music]
like no roller coaster
wait
we're going to the
can be guess not
guess we come into the store man it
can't be
wait stop oops
where should we go guys what's this what
the hell are we
good enough buddy
generate here
what we can switch these
that's so that we can go to camp I don't
know
yeah I guess I
Oh Rosie
I didn't know there was a locking
operation out here
stop giving up permits in the 60s
looks like some kind of a leech got a
way to turn it on
[Music]
was that building on
this again Arcadius
oh no oh yeah yes yep another one
oh it's hate okay let's watch this
yes
the donkey will begin to pull so pay
attention to the pressure
is found right here
what you done
I'll get some notes here in case you're
running this home
mm-hmm
okay where should we leave it then we'll
come back this
[Music]
oh the doors open maybe that's what he
had to do the main in shallots promising
[Music]
oh okay so we're at camp a the sumail is
their steam donkey there's a maintenance
shed
and another seem donkey down that in
account be I guess we have to get them
both running
come to the maintenance shed to pick up
the parts you wanted I guess I have to
go to the maintenance shed
which
further down here suspect
that's so dark
you have to push aside oh I can't write
but maybe there was somewhere in the
take them
bullets like dunk
so still a long time
yeah
maybe if I pulls it when it's at the
right gauge
[Music]
Steam's escaping it's a valve but the
handles missing okay we need to kill
this stuff let's go back and then down
here
yep
come on yeah I can take the wagon and
reverse it
[Music]
okay
[Music]
I did not like that I did not like this
way
now
ah
that's worse open to dark
what's down here
I didn't go down on me
Oh Yanni's goes to the maintenance shed
okay it's probably down
by the way just a heads up by probably
to be going about half Spanish but don't
worry this is becoming a regular
appearance so just at the moment we need
to upgrade our internet because when I
use what when i stream my housemate
cannot use the internet at all thank you
for the follow gyal yours didn't scare
me like the last tool in dude alright
dog we going we're going
that's my
I feel like we have been here before
the new one
excuse me are you [ __ ] me
what
what
he's been running the circle
where is this
bloody shefte
do I have to
see anything
[Music]
is it even this way I don't even know
[Music]
so check
[Music]
[Applause]
campaign
zim between campaign Cathy oh right it's
just off where we get stuck down here
look what did Adam we'll go back down
that way
hoping you know jump get it's time
bullets up
nice notice mr. Sheth dude what the hell
this changes every time my mind is so
confused right now can't do be there
let's go bullet
let's hope it's still standing why is he
not questioning why everything's
changing the game is making me feel
crazy
I don't achieve much for being fasten my
flashlight
[Music]
dude were you looking at
I can write he's gonna it makes me so
stressed out
ah
that's nice thank you
thank you for that
come in come in oh wait you already
yeah good dog
thank you Alex observer for your father
and for observing I guess
stick close to me come in
there it is
[Music]
keep it up
don't tug again how the hell did they
get here oh I'm such an aegis of course
these are the people that he fought with
and that's why he's getting confused
about seeing
[Music]
Sergius do you think these are all the
people that he knew as well now I feel
like these are unconnected cuz he didn't
act as spooked out by them
[Music]
don't leave me too too long though
you got it
ah Thank You cutie come here
aren't you a handsome boy
[Music]
Oh Alex II observer is Alex williamson's
blind adventures what thank you can
follow me on price YouTube and twitch oh
the club okay let's not she go inside
now
because uh she's honest
making order for more valves can't be to
the last one for that steam donkey now
without a spares
I don't even know what we need
do I
alright let's just ask my dog brown boy
my meal the things you got nothing now
No
is that all I need it for me than just
that
reading
shooting
look
not open this locker
deal where are you something is wit I
can hear stuff from the tree
[Music]
nothing there huh
[Music]
so if it's me making noise if it's
something else it's freaking me out
look I shouldn't venture to mom
is that all I need it
whatever we're going back
yeah
moment
ah that's like you Alex
thank you of course I know no I I just
talk a lot I was dr. Lao
we're popping now I'm confused about
whether it's the game just messing up or
not
remember trounce guys
can't be oh okay
we still can I get to can't be
wait did I pass that maintenance shed
before can you guys tell me because I
swear I didn't see it when we went round
there the first time
please don't jump-scare me while i'm
drinking water thank you
[Music]
okay come on
we're getting Austin to put this
there we go
don't time God so sorry
some missing as opposed the Belgian and
foul but how
don't be I don't know how
[Music]
I'm actually not selling
[Music]
what's the time okay
but okay for time
I don't know where to go now
try gonna can't be again I can't get to
can't be
it's blocked off
try walking that maybe
but let's just get [ __ ] in
wait
yeah tell y'all I'll try and walk
where are ya hear him I kind of see him
on in
run it let's go bullets are you
there you are you appear too thin and
you won't even hate this whole time you
haven't even real
Oh
come on
where the blood bobert
are you you can't know my thing but look
stop it dude
you stay with me
now get off the roads with me but
good boy
okay now we make the seed
please oh I think I took her purse I was
just too scared from the jump scare that
I missed it
okay cool
okay off we go we're gonna walk
well you're looking at wait okay I can't
see two logs
oh Jesus Christ
where's the doggy gum where's the doggy
on looking crazy look up in there
I was looking where the dog was looking
why am I here
why am I here
Wow
bullets
here
[Music]
see the dog
dog dog dog Duncan
ah it's so hot it's like just keep
looking with the dogs looking ex they
keep having to the [ __ ] dog and is it
on
I don't know wise of because a dog shows
you where it oh my god and why do I keep
Chris Kanyon nothing I know I keep
respawning back here all right that's
good to me
just but you talk to the dog's head yes
that would be such a good idea
see
okay Doug Doug Doug hey
I tell you what sports close to me yo
Aldo me
oh wait odo it's gonna run
hold up are we okay
well hello I can hear him but I can't
see him where are they oh here we go and
it begins he's everywhere apparently
absolutely everywhere dude did we break
the game because he is growling but
nothing's happening
yeah Oh Barney's over okay I'm running
boy where's the dog easy easy
ain't nothin but a ting wetware
[Music]
give me a cube a cuddle yeah good dog
okay and then stay with me please let's
go
I'm ready cold
psychological report illegible thank you
for the follow
Benjamin McFadden
I am scanty time thank you for following
me on both platforms all the platforms
sorry I had an inward birth background
summary and reasons for referral patient
brought in by parents due to extreme
panic attacks insomnia and seek walking
after a traumatic experience
I advise three therapeutic sessions per
week during a preliminary interview I
was able to determine the following
patient actively avoids recording the
event the experiences vivid nightmares
since the event possible copy
emotional numbness irrational aggression
and disassociation to the event our
world is very nervous possible
undiagnosed anxiety neurosis
that's our report spin now then it's
gotta be
they got a pin
I think this
nothing
[Music]
ready nothing else
what is sowed are we struggling sting
are you guys I think the other guys are
here
I'll get you that
yeah
stay close pull it
another one oh I forgot about these
weird little statue things
[Music]
it's got chokes by a little cable but we
didn't care
because we're manly men where are you
oh I'm lost where are you
show me the way seek
nothing
[Music]
but this don't look an indefinite
pathway I use the game trolling me like
this oh okay maybe not I take it back I
found something
oh here we go
it's one it's barely holding up see if
there's anything was salvaged
yeah got it
fantastic
I have a little bit
[Music]
Jack
dick dick dick dick
Turner
where is he
can you see anything find something
buddy
[Music]
nothing there huh
okay well in that case you get close to
me we're going back
hopefully nothing bad happens along the
way
[Music]
but it is probably unlikely something's
gonna happen either a story progression
is going to happen or jump-scare I'm
hoping for the first one
get down this way
give me a shortcut game I can't be asked
thank you
now that's good level design okay
we're keep sneaking a little arrow
[Music]
[Music]
wait was that water before
because who scared about the monster
but
time to go dude yeah
you're back with the things
[Music]
I want to sit down so I'm like in a
ditch so I can see but in my shop
I began to snow
we always go to smelly
oh yeah
a little bit brother
[Music]
that's preserve energy why not that's
our stop buddy
so now we've got to get it to the green
cool great
[Music]
we have to put coal in here isn't it
something else that we have to do
[Music]
where's the other thing that we found
look
[Music]
[Music]
where did the other thing go that we
found
[Music]
oh that is okay syrup is this
maybe if I
what's the tape again
I can't pose it as a fun time
look at this I can do night vision
yeah fire so doesn't know where to get
you but maybe if I
pulls it when
ah there we go it's got fire now see
what I mean get to change the game it's
so cool
[Music]
oh it isn't the green
and then what we do when it gets in the
grain upon them
the roads clear up on buddy back on
track no that's fine
give me
[Music]
about that
back
what
none
but up
[Music]
Oh
Oh No what oh my god this way again wait
wait wait hold up hold up
[Music]
and it gives us no money goes backwards
it's a loop just let it loop really
no I think I think it went laughed it's
supposed to go straight on
right
yeah I'm supposed to go over there
the obviously changed the tracks for me
but I changed them back
come on
yeah wow that looks like it's the right
way
I don't want to go that way
I'm gonna go that way
just try
jump off
no yellow dick why are you going away
[Music]
why we'll try once more
it doesn't work then screw it I'm just
let it go
forwards then just go let it loose
can I come buddy
come on
Hey
[Music]
now we're going away
you okay
oh I don't know I said yeah but that's a
soul
[Music]
[Music]
these trees are so sparse at least we
can see more here
glass is met here at bullet
[Music]
oh this is where I was
directly I wouldn't have been able to
yeah the floors lava death paint on
the white choice of gun
don't look at me there we'll be out of
here soon
don't stuff down
a little further
nope
that's quite pretty
basically the reason
[Music]
oh thank god you're all we care about
bullet
[Music]
that's what stuff buddy trucha call
thing
[Music]
yes yep I needed I know but of course
I'm not gonna tell you then I know I'm
not making any sense right now but
that's the thing okay hideous Aneesa I
got to know if they're real or not I
don't know what just worse it's hard to
explain
remember you said that bad memories can
I have one now please I don't know why I
want some train tracks the music
abruptly stops
bullet bullet take your time why don't
you aren't you a handsome boy
oh wait I should want me to give you a
snack cuz you've been through you've
been through some stoves so wait dude
I'm having your snack
okay wait I'll wait then
nobody go down there you bum it to your
boys let me go through some grimy ass
I love just rot down wanna stay here but
it's valid balle balle balle
what I'll be walking around right boy
good letter that's nice about it okay
you're right that good uh now I'm gonna
give you a to heal
you want some point
why is he pursued in this case solo you
must approve you still got it yeah
basically well I don't think he did it
on purpose really he went to join an
investigation but everyone was already
there without him and now he's gone into
deed basically
but there definitely was some aspect of
him wanting to prove himself to like his
ex co-workers and stuff we wanted to
show that he was better
what is it something in there boy find
out
we can add a gun we can shoot that
barrel bullets away mom I'm not
abandoned someone lives here yeah
this again Raphael would it be weird if
like sometimes you you let obviously
meet the name and you come back and they
have changed and they're facing you just
like once in a very very rare moment I
want that to happen that would be so
cool
for the people like me who check every
detail
ha
what's it
my dog wants me love it something deal
what oh that's her what is it oh crap
I don't like this is too many noises
locked
- wait didn't I just see blood Oh guys
did I see blood or not did I see blood
dripping am I seeing things I'm actually
very pleased did you guys see blood
dripping please tell me did you see
blood dripping digit digit digit did you
did I'm pretty confused did I just make
that up because I can hear dripping I
thought I could see some Adam
you didn't oh my god I'm going crazy
okay well well there's blood on the
toilet sweet there ah here you go
there's the blood I'll thank God I'm not
crazy
I thought I was crazy I'm not crazy it's
right there so tasty I'm not losing it
I'm not losing it
don't tell me I'm losing it well I'm
plenty not losing this right here it's
right here never trusting you guys again
so I am going to watch that tape again
maybe he runs through the door and I can
make it open
there you go
now it's open you come here together
little cutie every Brian does not wanna
come inside here I mean I don't blame
honest
bullet doesn't want to come outside
won't budge
oh that's weird I can't move the door
why
it'll only open this much 3 3 to 4 Oh
the padlock the padlock ok remember this
one guys
3 3 to 4 and shut up Valbuena I'm not
crazy I'm not crazy 3 C 4 C 3 C 4 2 3 2
4 3 3 2 45240 suited for Barbara
ba-ba-ba-ba-bom Bob Robert Rob Bob Bob
for the Bob Bob Bob but nothing's ever
gonna happen it's like the whole Bloody
Mary Jesus I don't know if they did that
on purpose but that was a great jump
scare
I saw it not a witch or a monster but a
man a man carrying the pelt of a skinned
human he saw me and now he's coming
I don't know about this
to to throw to a digit 3 4 2 2 3
[Music]
yeah good dog
2 2 3 4 3 3 2 4 oh my god
I don't know I'll trust you guys 3 3 3
oh ok I will trust you guys
you burned my trust back well then
to here
he's not coming
reason we want to come inside these
houses as a yeah
I think we've just walked in on
something that we should have
I think someone's having some a long
time Oh God
oh yeah there was dripping blood
where he sounds like he's in that oh he
isn't that right look over this way then
Jesus oh my god
can you hear me badly mutilated some of
those are in defense wounds
blood still fresh
let me just it's one of this
uh what's real what's the real Jesus
closed what the [ __ ] just happened
[Music]
maybe I'm the killer what if I'm the
killer
[Music]
a chance someone right into the
collarbone
[Music]
face come on
I'm in that room that that mom was just
in
okay I mean we haven't seen ourselves
yeah I don't think we're wearing that
Oh God
sorry buddy
to do that
right how much time have we got left
oh okay I think I'm gonna stop it there
so that my housemate can actually use
the Internet but what a great way to
ends it right yeah
guy I mean it just says somebody makes
senses we're not the killer then how the
hell did we survive like where is he
doesn't actually
but I guess now that the world is
turning maybe something's happened
outside the game Oh bullet
nah okay
who is that
all right we'll just go outside then
we'll then we'll stop playing the game
don't yell every time come on oh no I
need to go save [ __ ] other dog yet
right
No
you
you killed landing
[Music]
the where's Peter what have you done to
him
[Music]
stop messing with me or what
weak scared
[Music]
[Music]
well that goes my theory out the winter
c'mon now kiss new where is he taking me
her well the which I'm guessing guessing
so
what are you doing here private it was
me sir what was Elisha 5 I was the point
man sir what are you trying to say
soldier I let those men into the ambush
sir
nine injured six dead six grieving
widows
orphan children
a soldier
he should've been court-martialed
I couldn't stay
but after that it wasn't your fault
Ellis
easy so easy oh you're so weak I was
weak like you once see this knife I
remember holding it against my wrist
pressing it deeper and deeper wanting to
end it all to silence the voices weak
pathetic I should have listened from the
start that's what set me free you'll
understand soon enough and that happens
after every cutscene like of his PTSD
flashbacks
he's gone
Wow I just left yeah he didn't kill you
bullet
oh listen to this what do you want a bad
feeling about this
patient in Vermont woman in relation to
his anxiety neurosis seems captain check
again no discussion of the woods or his
friend disassociate from the worsening I
admit this patient it's beginning to
concern me everyone seems to have moved
on but the fact that he does not talk
about the woods at all okay it's almost
eerie he has become interested in hiking
hunting was offered a scholarship out of
state but does not want to leave town
something is keeping him here
it's all rotten but how I'd have taken
years for it to get this bad
[Music]
the camera it's a taping it bloody hands
like his hands a super bloody I don't
know something's going up here did he
help kill did it kill lot of others hand
Wilson Ellis this is nothing personal
there I swear
she wants you she didn't see the boy
okay here's the boy life here's what I
want you to do go to the tree
branches
as I say
[ __ ] bastard
what the hell is wha
what
not okay
Patrick Patrick Patrick Patrick Patrick
but
right I don't know what he was like what
the hell is this too
right now I'm actually go so thank you
so much to everyone here watch tonight
we yeah this is leaving on a a very
interesting note isn't it
we've got a lot more to learn but I'm
interested to see more so if you are and
I think you are then let me know but
anyway thank you so much for joining me
tonight make sure that you're following
me on Twitter for updates on when I'm
going to stream next and also I do have
a discord and it's it's a pretty awesome
server if I do say so myself I'll give
you I give you a little invite to it no
limit and never expire with the link so
yeah you can all join the discourse we
just chat about a lot of stuff but also
if you have any games that you'd like to
see me play or just wanna be updated on
what I'm doing in my day to day life
then discord is pretty good for that and
then also there's Twitter which I often
they my Instagram if you wanna see
Instagram stuff thank you so much 90
Spoony live for following I appreciate
that
here's my Instagram
doodoo okay okay so I'm gonna go make
some dinner and have a lovely day or
evening I'll say goodbye to whoever I
could see in the chat so goodbye
[Music]
Benjamin McFadden by Michael Tanner
goodbye deaf one five seven goodbye I
hate my elbow goodbye your retirement
goodbye Michael tannic goodbye Maria
Maria pizza goodbye Alex observer
goodbye
peridot 23 zip and thank you for joining
because you said you were new I hope you
enjoyed goodbye
90 Spoony life thanks again for the
follow and give I'd anyone who I've
missed or that isn't available in the
chat right now but you're still watching
I still appreciate you and I'll see you
next time have